inflation hits everyone but the greatest
impact is felt by workers especially
those on lower wages
all of argentina's main trade unions
representing teachers construction and
health workers truck drivers and civil
servants marched on congress to support
the government and to demand restraint
from the businesses that set prices
one of the main problems is the
hyperinflation we have been experiencing
for some time now we are against paying
the international monetary fund which is
reflected in the lack of jobs there are
no jobs wages are not enough permanent
price increases that's why argentine
workers are on the streets today
inflation in argentina in july hits 7.4
per cent it's projected to reach around
100 for the year
inflation is an indicator of a weak
economy
argentina's is a victim of crippling
foreign debt and like the rest of the
world the pandemic and the rising cost
of fuel and flower caused by the war in
ukraine
these marches behind me are from the
province of chaco in the far north of
argentina they've come from all over the
country because inflation hits workers
the hardest seeing the value of their
wages diminishing week by week month by
month
the government on tuesday cut subsidies
for households fuel and water bills
saying it would refocus on those most in
need
however with prices rising weekly those
needs are growing the latest official
figures show more than one-third of
argentines living in poverty
we are suffering from inflation and the
peso has collapsed against the dollar so
it's tough but we have got work we are
not protesting we just want the
government to see what we need
the workers are supporting the
government in its right to make things
better we're not asking them for
anything we're supporting them
others are running out of patience with
the government under pressure to find
solutions to a problem that has blighted
argentina for many years
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires